[Music]
here's your money briefing for Thursday
March 9th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
for years investors have held on to the
belief that there is no alternative to
stocks but after last year's series of
sell-offs in this year's choppy market
performance investors are seeing money
market opportunities outside the stock
market wsj markets reporter akani Otani
joins us to discuss how you can take
advantage of these alternatives to
stocks to build up your portfolio akani
thank you so much for being with us
thanks for having me so akani you know
we saw stocks take a beating last year
to the tune of a 19 decline in the S P
500 then they got a bit of a bounce at
the start of this year but what's gotten
us to the point where investors at all
levels should be thinking about
alternatives to stocks well Jr I think
there's two main factors driving that
shift in mindset one is the fact that
there's a lot of worry about when the
economy is going to go into recession
and how bad that potentially might be
for Corporate America as we know the
stock market does heavily tend to rely
on corporate earnings so so there's this
thought that if we go into a downturn
other markets might offer investors a
bit more of a chance at a safe return
than the stock market and then the
second factor is the fact that interest
rates have continued to rise we know
that the FED intends on raising interest
rates at least a couple more times this
year and that means that other assets
like bonds for instance are offering
investors a lot more yield for their
money so take the two factors together
and you have a lot of money managers
saying stocks don't necessarily look
like the best or the only Market to be
in right now but if stocks have come
down in value wouldn't it make sense to
maybe jump in and grab a bargain you
would think so but a lot of money
managers actually say the stock market
especially in the US still doesn't
necessarily look cheap so of course yes
the S P 500 had a terrible year last
year we saw big declines across the
board and many of the most popular
stocks in the market but if you look at
most sort of broad measures of
valuations or trying to figure out how
expensive the stock market is in general
we're seeing the S P 500 trade above
long-term historical averages still so
it still looks more expensive than on
average we've seen over the past decade
so that has a lot of investors thinking
the risk reward ratio doesn't
necessarily look super compelling right
now all right so let's talk about what
this means for people with a nest egg
that includes stocks and perhaps a
retirement account you mentioned bonds
and what types of alternatives to stocks
including bonds have gotten investors
attention and how could someone with a
portfolio consider changing the blend of
the assets that they have right so one
of the most popular alternatives to
stocks always and not just in this kind
of environment has been historically
bonds because you're basically
guaranteed to get 100 your return on
money if you hold the bond to maturity
plus the interest payments over time
that those bonds will pay out and right
now a lot of bonds are actually paying
in this sort of single high to Mid
single digit percentage range and that's
a lot more than bonds have been offering
for a very long period after the 2008
financial crisis so that's one reason
why we're seeing a lot of investors say
bonds look like a compelling alternative
to the stock market right now and then
another area just generally that
investors have seen some interest in
investors among is Emerging Markets so
we're talking about markets where the
economy is still developing so big
Emerging Markets tend to be like China a
lot of countries in Africa a lot of sort
of your South Asian economies and
investors are saying that stocks bonds
real estate things in those markets are
looking a lot more compelling as as well
so for somebody who doesn't trade for a
living you know doesn't have a stock
trading degree is there a simple way for
them to take advantage of those types of
Investments so what I've been hearing
from a lot of financial advisors and
investors is that it's never wise to
completely pull out all of the money
that you have right now and then go like
a hundred percent into a different
Market it's more about gradually
Shifting the mix of assets that you have
so maybe right now you're 60 in U.S
stocks and 40 in U.S bonds well one type
of shift that we've been seeing is some
investors are recommending their clients
shift that 60 in U.S stocks so maybe
they're more like 50 in U.S stocks and
10 in emerging market stocks we're
talking gradual shifts like that another
common shift that we've been seeing a
lot of investors talk about is putting a
bit more money into Cash which is
interesting because again for many years
after the 2008 financial crisis it kind
of seemed like a loss to just put your
money into cash and is such actually
earn no money on that at all if it's
sitting in your bank account but now
with interest rates Rising a lot of
investors have been saying cash and cash
like Investments are actually offering
somewhat more of a compelling return
especially just considering all of the
uncertainty that we still have about the
economy it's sort of nice for a lot of
investors to think well if everything
goes down I still have a little bit of
cash in my accounts that I can fall back
on so akani I want to ask you more about
cash in a moment but with regard to
emerging markets and bonds how would
somebody take advantage of those types
of Investments well I think one of the
easiest ways for individuals to get into
investing in general is ETFs and mutual
funds of course you could always
theoretically just go into individual
Securities so you could look up let's
say an electric vehicle maker in China
and just purchase shares of that company
yourself but it tends to be easier for
folks who don't have a day-to-day focus
on trading to actually just invest their
money into broader funds so these are
sort of run by institutions and fund
managers who hand pick what's going into
these funds in the case of mutual funds
and they sort of take care of portfolio
selection for you all right and now
regarding cash we often hear about the
benefits of looking into stocks with
strong dividends as a way to make money
in the market why has that particular
approach lost some luster and where
could an investor look to generate some
cash
talk about
fashion dividend and what we tend to
think about is dividend yields so a lot
of stocks in the S P 500 will pay out a
dividend it can be every quarter every
two quarters but basically you're
getting a regular cash payment every
year and it makes those stocks a little
bit similar to bonds for a very long
time after the 2008 financial crisis
because interest rates had hit rock
bottom sometimes you could get dividend
yields from stocks that were actually a
lot better than what you could get from
say treasury bonds or treasury notes but
now the opposite situation has
materialized where on average a stock in
the S P 500 will offer a dividend yield
of about 1.7 percent and in comparison a
six-month U.S treasury bill might offer
you a yield of closer to five percent
and that's up a lot in fact that was
trading at around zero percent at the
start of 2022 another area where a lot
of investors have had luck gener
generating cash is through money market
funds which now offer yields above four
percent again up from almost zero not
that long ago so there have been a lot
of different markets that are now
offering higher yields than they have in
a very long time and that's all making
the stock market look a little bit less
attractive to investors all right that's
Wall Street Journal markets reporter
akanio Tani akani thank you so much for
being with us thanks for having me a
Metro money briefing I'm J.R Whalen for
the Wall Street Journal
[Music]
thank you